we're going to talk about actually this
neuromorphic nanoelectronic materials
which is a hell of a mouthful so you got
in touch
on i don't know about a month ago or so
i've lost all track of time under these
circumstances
you said it's a while since we did
something in the links between nano and
computing i said it has it is indeed
and then actually just before that
i've been reading this month so at the
time that month's
issue of nature nanotechnology which is
one of the key nanotechnology journals
and this is a review paper in that
there's a
massive push to integrate nano
electronics
with computing of course to push down
the limits of computing but
to actually integrate different ways of
processing
information that go far beyond
what's known as the von neumann
architecture
i think you've done the von neumann
architecture before on computer file i
think dave did a video on it so i'm sure
sean will put the link
in somewhere the key bottleneck when it
comes to von neumann is that we've got
a central processing unit and we've got
memory the bottom neck is that we've got
a transfer between those two units
that's not what our brain does our brain
doesn't have a cpu over here and memory
over here and transfer between the two
and that transfer is not only limits
bandwidth
it also limits the ability to train
these systems and although there's a
vast amount of work in machine learning
countless computer video
computer file videos on machine learning
i think we've even done one in the past
shown um on on machine learning
but it seems a little bit strange in
that what we're doing is we're taking
the machine
learning idea artificial neural nets and
we're imposing it on the von neumann
architecture which is very different
from how our brains are work
how our brains work so then the question
is well
can we change the substrate can we
change the architecture so we get
something which is a bit more brain-like
the other key issue with von neumann is
it's incredibly energy hungry
in this paper there's a study that's
quoted that says
by 2040 we're going to need 10 to the 27
10 to the power 27 jewels to continue on
doing cmos
logic as we currently do that's a real
problem because that's more than the
energy budget of the entire world at the
moment
but um surely the energy's efficiency is
driving down as well in cmos right the
energy
efficiency is getting you know sorry i
meant to say yes yeah it's getting
better
yeah so the energy it's it yes so we're
making improvements but
we've still got this key bottleneck and
key latency
that's the other thing there will always
be an inherent latency with the von
neumann architecture because you've got
to transfer information between these
two
so the key thing is why can't we
co-locate
why can't we have the memory and the
processing in the same place because
that's what our brain does
and moreover this is incredibly energy
efficient
on no more than i don't know a banana
and a cup of coffee and sean got me a
cup of coffee this morning so i'm
fairly fired up at the moment and no
more than that
i can solve problems in terms of face
recognition and in terms of
identification of different people or
different objects that it takes
countless cpu hours to train a machine
learning algorithm to do so in many ways
we can
beat a computer and the key issue the
key reason for that is because we've got
this different architecture in our heads
one comment that always comes up is why
didn't he discuss this why didn't he
discuss this why didn't he discuss this
it's a five or ten minute video we can't
discuss everything and i just want to
try and get
how large this field is a survey of
neuromorphic computing and neural
networks and hardware
2 682 references
the reference list is much much longer
than the paper itself
so this is a huge field i can only
scratch the surface
hopefully if computer via viewers are
interested in this we can do maybe
more videos on this because it is it
really is a fascinating area
anyway where will we start so
one thing that comes up time and time
again is this word
memristor memorists are synapses for
neuromorphic computing
nanoscale memorists are devices synapse
and neuromorphic systems
review of memories to devices in
neuromorphic computing memorists with
diffusive dynamics the synaptic
emulators for neuromorph computing etc
etc it comes up time and time again so
we've got two words there synapse and
memristor
how does the sort of processing unit in
here work
how does the brain work how does any
brain work how does any biological brain
work
well you have neurons and you have
synapses and synapses are the gaps
between neurons
and those neurons communicate with each
other
via well how do they do that they do
that via what are called
neurotransmitters
and you you program these
you set the state is probably the best
way if we're going to talk about
computing language you set the state of
those neurons
by controlling the ion flow so
in a cell you've got ions inside you've
got ions outside what's an ion an ion is
a charged atom so you've got potassium
you've got chloride you've got calcium
you've got a range of different ions
and a neuron is really and certainly a
synapse is
really an electrical device so what it's
doing
it's it's we're controlling electrical
current due to those ions the charged
particles we're controlling how they
flow
therefore we have an electrical device
that's how a computer works
what do we do in a computer we control
where the electrons go we control where
the charge goes
so the question is why can't we take
this architecture
and put it into the solid state and
that's exactly what neuromorphic
computing is all about the question
is now can we develop an artificial
synapse and to develop an artificial
synapse
we need an electrical device that's got
a memory effectively
that instead of just we pass a current
we put a voltage across and we pass a
current through it
in a standard resistor there's no memory
of what's happened there's no memory of
that current
to really get what the brain is doing
and certainly to get learning
and to get memory we need to have a
memory we need to have
the the device the synapse the
artificial synapse
remember what happened to it in the past
we need a component
with it with us a memory that's a simple
component
that we can synthesize that we can
fabricate
moreover not just that we can fabricate
but that we can
fabricate easily and also scale so we
can get lots and lots and lots of these
on a chip
we also don't just want to mimic what's
happening with cmos we don't have
the same we face the same problem again
in terms of energy dissipation so we
want something that doesn't have the
same level of energy dissipation and
causes the same amount of heat
because this we can do a lot as i said
on 20 watts
gpus are taking hundreds of watts and
you've
you know it's an awful lot of heat
energy being generated it's an awful lot
of energy being wasted
so we've got to try and push that
efficiency up back
in 2008 and i've scribbled all over this
i apologize
there was this paper which has caused a
great deal of controversy
as you can see the missing memristor
found so i'll write a blog post on this
so to fill in the details some of you
i know are really interested in maths
some of you are not interested in maths
i'll write a blog post that puts
the mathematical detail in but basically
up until this point the argument is we
had resistor
capacitor and inductor we've got four
key variables here voltage
current charge and the magnetic flux
because once we've got
moving charges once we've got current
we've got a magnetic field
this group claim as i say it's
controversial
claim that they found the memristor they
found this component we were looking for
for years and it turns out that that's
exactly what we
need for an artificial synapse and it's
why all those papers have neuromorphic
computing with memorisers
because the memristor is a really simple
way
and it's a really simple to fabricate
device that allows us to make an
artificial synapse
12 years of research since that paper
though i mean surely somebody's come up
with something better or something that
people
isn't controversy you said yeah it's
controversial in terms of what
is that really a fundamental component
but what absolutely isn't controversial
and even those who will argue
against the fact that it is a
fundamental component or not will say
this in terms of neuromorphic computing
in terms of mimicking here
it is a massive step forward how does a
memristor work
i would say an extreme example of a
memristor is a
fuse you pass a current through it and
it blows
it's got a pretty extreme memory of the
last state before it blew
that's not particularly useful because
it's dead obviously but you can have a
much
less extreme version of that whereby
you do something to the material as you
pass a current through it
so when you stop you know you don't
apply the voltage anymore the current
isn't flowing
you halt it at that particular point so
it's got a memory
and what do you do in terms of
controlling that resistance
you do in many ways exactly what the
brain does or what the neurons
and the the the biological architecture
of the brain does
is you control iron flow and so in that
particular hewlett packard paper
they had titanium dioxide which is an
insulator usually
so very well used material in particular
when it comes to solar cell technology
it's very important
and they had regions of that sample
which were doped which means they had
impurities which
changed the conductivity and regions
which were undoped and the important
thing is what happens
is when they put the voltage on they
cause those impurities to diffuse all
right
and so that means they change the
conductivity those impurities
move under the influence of the electric
field so we've got a voltage across this
sample
and that creates an electric field this
is a tiny variable resistor
that's exactly it that is a very good
way of thinking about it showing
wonderful it's a tiny variable resistor
potentiometer like that obviously if we
have a volume
you know you just turn it to a certain
volume and that's it's that
that's what we're doing in in essence
we're changing but we're doing it
at the level of changing the material
properties
this is a really simple very
unsophisticated
demo but what we have is
the box represents our sample and these
yellow balls
represent the impurity atoms in that
sample what happens in the real sample
is you have a voltage and that generates
an electric
field across the device and that causes
these impurities to move
we're not going to put an electrostatic
potential on this we're going to put a
gravitational potential on this but it's
the same general idea you have a
gradient in the field
and that causes the particles to move
and by causing the particles to move you
change the resistance of the device
so with a normal resistor we're just
going to do ohm's law we're just going
to do v
is equal to ir you'll allow me just one
equation shown
linear so we've got current versus
voltage and
you do that current depends linearly on
voltage
but more importantly you increase the
voltage you decrease the voltage you
increase the voltage you decrease the
voltage you follow this line back and
forth
so that's for a traditional resistor
normal component
bug standard resistor that we find in
practically every circuit
for a memristor the most important
difference
is that instead of it
being exactly the same curve every time
because you are changing the device when
you apply a voltage to it
when you change those impurities and
move them around it means you have
hysteresis it means you have a memory so
the current voltage curve you get on the
way up
is not the same as the current voltage
curve you get on the way down
and we have what's called a hysteresis
loop and that gives us memory
and it's really really elegant because
it's controlling it's
exactly analogous in many ways to the
biological system because the reason
we're getting this hysteresis the reason
we're getting this memory is because
we're controlling iron flow
but not in a liquid you can do it in a
liquid and there are examples of
neuromorphic computing in the liquid
but with the laptop you know you don't
have a lot of liquid in a laptop it's a
solid-state device and what we're doing
is we're translating that biological
computing
to a solid state platform and we've got
memory from a practical point of view
how would that hysteresis be
used just like neurons spike
so neurons spike they send a potential
spike
um and that controls the that's how you
learn
you have what's called short-term
plasticity and long-term potentiation
so what will happen is you will have
connections that last a short amount of
time with this what you do is you spike
you create a snapshot of where the ion
concentration is and you remember that
and then if you keep going what you can
even do is to mimic long-term learning
in the brain
is what will happen is that those ions
will connect and you'll have a
connection
um throughout the device which forms a
long-term connection just like you
form neural pathways you form pathways
which are due to those atoms interacting
and actually bonding all the way across
the
across the gap it's like what i find
amazing is when you're learning to drum
even simple things like just putting
those bun john bonham style triplets
where you put one drum after the other
da
da da da da da da da da da da you start
off with that
and you do it at 80 beats a minute you
do it at a particular slow rate and then
you build it up gradually up until the
point where
i could never have done that two weeks
ago and that's because you're
burning those pathways into your brain
you're setting those you're solidifying
those neural pathways that's what's
happening you can also do that in these
artificial synapses which is amazing to
an ip and then i can actually
communicate with that server to do
whatever it was i wanted to do
so just to clarify if i put in computer
file.website or something yeah
something somewhere needs to know where
to find that there will be usually one
or two
i'd be removed 25 and 35 and then i get
seven
and so on so we repeat